all right ted well we're just days away
from a big celebration st patrick's day
but with the recent shortages of a lot
of food and beverage items all across
the country how are local bars coping
madison kimbrough stopped by a couple of
local bars to hear how they're preparing
to keep those crowds satisfied
denise many bars anticipating an even
bigger turnout this year than before the
pandemic so stocking up on particular
items was key even if that means
ordering months in advance
we're going to be probably busier than
we were prior to us closing down before
the pandemic for sure st patrick's day
is right around the corner and with it
comes a lot of expectation from those
who plan to celebrate over at
hennessey's tavern general manager chris
olinder says it's all about planning
ahead
we're ordered 30 kegs of guinness we've
ordered 25 kegs of poor's light
we've ordered a thousand pounds of
corned beef to cook off for corn beef
cabbage dinners and reuben sandwiches
we've been planning for about a month
right now just for st patrick's day but
even so some food items and liquor have
not been easy to find for us
we're having difficulty getting tequilas
from mexico whiskeys from canada
some of the whiskeys from ireland are on
short supply corned beef we had to order
two months ahead of time to find out
just to make sure we have not enough on
hand over in the arts district at
cornish pasty they say being a local
business has helped them tremendously in
purchasing items but does note one must
have that has been hard to get coming up
into the holidays
a lot of the distributors will sometimes
try and allocate certain items for
smaller businesses like us which has
been really nice glassware has been one
thing that has been an issue we haven't
been able to stock up on those so we'll
be using plastic for majority of the
night
but as for beer both places say they are
fully stocked with guinness and irish
car bombs ready to serve live in the
newsroom madison kimbrough live local
now
madison thank you